-Also, it is a very
exciting week
for us here at "Late Night"
because Fred Armisen
is back with us on the show.
-Thank you.
-And, Fred,
I share this
with the audience
any time you're here.
I am always overwhelmed
by how many different projects
you have going at one time,
and then you also
do things not for you,
not to enrich yourself
financially or artistically,
but for other people.
And I heard you're doing
an incredible thing.
You are counterprogramming
Halloween for kids
who don't like trick
or treating.
-Finally, yes.
-Yeah.
-So I'm doing something
where kids
can start rehearsing
for other holidays.
Like, you know,
Christmas or Hanukkah
or Easter or whatever it is,
they could start
just doing a rehearsal
just to get ready
for birthdays and things.
The problem is
kids aren't ready.
-Okay.
-So we bring them --
-They, like, sort of get
caught off guard, say, by like,
hey, it's Thanksgiving.
And they're like...
-Yes, that's exactly
what I mean.
So, like, let's sit
around a table,
let's have imaginary food.
Let's kind of like
go through it
so you're not nervous about it,
and it goes for birthdays, too.
Do you know how to say
happy birthday to someone?
Do you know how to like...?
-Oh, so it's not
just for your birthday,
but if you get invited
to a birthday,
you can rehearse for that.
-It just takes away
the nervousness.
-Yeah.
-So when they come --
-This is something that you're
doing uniquely
on October 31st,
if you don't want
to trick or treat,
you go to --
where do you go?
-So, it's in Central Park.
-Okay.
-And so there's a --
there's like all these
bicycle rentals there,
and it's just right next to it.
But please don't crowd in
because all the tourists
are trying to grab the bicycles.
So we're just asking everyone
to like please, please,
please move over.
There's like an area
that has like a little bit
of grass and cement.
Please don't crowd the bicycles.
We're just asking.
-Now, why?
You seem so concerned
about crowding
the bicycle rack,
why would you do it?
Why would you set up there?
Because you're almost talking
more about the bicycle
rack situation
than you are about
the actual holiday rehearsal.
-It's just because
they get so mad.
The people who rent out
the bikes are always kind of
like they take it out on me
and they start yelling at me
about it,
and I'm like, I can't hand--
You know, these are kids.
You know what I mean?
So kids, they
just wander around,
and we're just asking, please,
just stay on the cement,
just stay on the pavement
and we could do
the rehearsals from there.
-Okay, great.
And if people
want to learn more about this,
is there a website
they can go to?
-No, but I asked them
to talk to you.
[ Laughter ]
-Give it up for
Fred Armisen, everybody.
-Thank you.
Thank you.